today's episode is brought to you by
magic mind
and you want to know for a fact that
flow state
now comes in a bottle and you can drink
it you can devour it
i like to shake mine and then have it
oh yeah you can check it out
magicmind.co
use promo code theo for 10 off
if you're tired of coffee then try this
today's episode features a beautiful man
and this is a comedy man and
and he's got so many big things
happening in his life i think um
i'm just amazed we're even able to have
him in here today
and he's a man of comedy and you know
him from netflix and television
ladies and gentlemen my friend mr joe
[Music]
coy
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
i've been dating a girl on and off for a
couple years and then now i think we're
not dating so i'm just chilling
are you in your head a lot like do you
hear words underneath sentences or do
you like
it's kind of like paranoia because we're
in a certain position now
does that make sense like what do you
mean like like okay like i
know i know that i
like i make a certain amount of money i
i know a lot of people
like you know what i mean like it we're
not looked at the same way
this is gonna sound so air i don't want
to sound i don't
you could sound arrogant though i think
some people could sound arrogant i don't
think
it's something that you could do so i
think no matter what you say it's coming
from a place where it's like okay i'm
just trying to share what i'm
feeling or that that's how i feel so uh
it it hinders my dating life
really yeah man and i and i hate it
because i
my trust is so it's i've been burned a
lot
by you know by people i've dated and
then and then
and just like my trust is just so bad
like
what are you in this for why are you
with me why like there's only one person
i really trust and that's my son's
mom she was with me when i had [ __ ] up
teeth
when i was working at nordstrom rack and
and borders
traveling doing coke uh working at uh
some marina del rey cleaning yachts and
then running over to laugh factory and
doing stage time
so she was there yeah i trust her
i don't trust anyone that came after
this that's what sucks man it really
sucks do you sometimes i
do you feel bad for not like committing
to the yeah to the mom
no i think we both have like a great
understanding man we're
if anyone gets a divorce her and i
should write a book because we are the
greatest divorce
couple of all time if my mom and dad
could have just done
what we did i mean we'd have a great
life right now like i
like maybe i wouldn't be so ptsd about
my
my childhood you know what i mean yeah i
wouldn't be so
holding on to certain feelings that i've
had you know with my mom and my dad
you know yeah it's damaging man like
those relationships and then you start
to
exhibit the same relation you you you
exude and
and do the same practices that were done
to you and i was starting to theo
when we first divorced i was i was being
that
guy you know i'll make it harder for
this [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah wow yeah struggle [ __ ] oh
yeah
i was like i remember my mom's like you
remember how you felt when and
ah [ __ ] i don't want to put that out
there but you know i love my dad you
know what i mean but
they were going through a time and i
didn't see my dad
and um and and i don't ever want my son
to feel that feeling
yeah of the dad not around yeah and
being a phone dad happy birthday son
like
it [ __ ] hurts man yeah and um and i
see it with you that's why i
i i don't know what i you know i i don't
dig into you but when you do your like
your single mom shows
yeah that comes from a place right like
is it because your mom was single
yeah my mom was single i think yeah i
think sometimes you know we just sent
some
money out to some single miles we'll
like every now and then just write out
some check just
nothing crazy a couple hundred bucks
just no but that's so dope but we have
like a little group that we kind of try
to add to over the time
but it's funny because i was thinking
the other day like why do we do like
what
and i think it's just like i think
because i i wish maybe somebody had like
given my mom some extra money to do
something or and not that these women
even need it they might all be rich i
have no idea yeah
but um but you're also setting a trend
and starting something new like
as long as you can plant the seed yeah
as long as like you know you have a
beautiful platform and you speak to a
lot of people
a lot of kids too and if they see
something like that
that's inspirational that that teaches
them not to you know oh theo did it
right and that's that's something i
didn't have i don't know how old you are
i'm 40 years old so i'm older than you
not by much
but but enough to like during my time
i think divorce was new oh wow i mean
i think divorce was new and was there
shame with divorce then yeah like there
was that's when all the divorce
courts started coming out and all the
divorce shows were coming out
and you know i mean it was all new for
everybody you know and and
and you know i don't i don't i don't i
don't get mad at my dad i
you know i tell my dad i love you so
much all the time but
um i also tell them i understand yeah
you know i mean like it was a different
time yeah it was a different time
it was like their their role models were
like had like drove like um
ford ltd's or whatever yeah they had a
pistol
yeah yeah six shooters with old bullets
it was different
yeah it was different time they always
went off because there was no safety
safety that guy right they always had
uncles that told dirty jokes oh it was
disgusting but they were dirty jokes
that they got from a book
yeah remember there was a book they used
to sell it was like they they used to
have like the worst
dirty books i remember going there as a
kid and said do you do you know what i'm
talking about
i don't remember that i remember i was
like truly tasteless books
please look it up nick put it up nick
when i was a kid thanks bud i remember a
kid came to us
to the school and this thing called the
truly tasteless
jokes and was he hiding it from the
adult oh it was yeah it was it was
it was like a satanic book you know what
i mean and we all gathered around
during lunch and we all pulled it out
and just died
died laughing the most crudest nastiest
things you could ever
read we used to have a fella we used to
pay to had a dude who you'd pay him a
couple dollars and he would draw you a
piece of
little crotch at recess this dude nick
bro
was it nick was his name what was his
name nick
i don't remember this guy's name but
yeah man for a couple dollars he's
sketching out a beautiful piece
and it just looked like it huh bro and
if you had one of those you were good
for the weekend you know
you were if you had a couple dollars to
get you a little sketch
yes man and i remember i used to bike
across town to go ma
they had this man and he uh
he had a family yeah and i would go over
to his house and i was like buddies with
his son
and they had pornography up under the
sink yeah
that's where it was oh and i'd bike five
miles over to their house on the weekend
did it to go to the bathroom to pretend
i was pooping for like an
hour oh and it was massive right it was
a massive poop you didn't even poop
yeah dude and i'm just in there just
feeling sorry about myself then i had to
come out of the bathroom and pretend to
be friends with their son for a while
yeah and then you also had to let your
semi go down oh because just because
you're done it does it's not
not it doesn't go back to it's it's
resting place
it still has a lot of energy a little
life
oh yeah yeah you're still kind of
excited too you think you could probably
do it again
oh yeah you're ready like i'm just yeah
i'm just wait i'm like building up steam
to get back in there you know
my friend's dad had a stack of magazines
in his bathroom and i always wanted to
use
his dad's bathroom yeah it was on top of
the you know the tank
and it was like sports illustrated
sports illustrated and then another
magazine mechanics popular mechanics and
then
and then the goodies tits only oh yeah
jugs
oh jugs yeah he just had to use he had
to remember what magazine was on top
yes remember all that you had to pull it
out slowly
don't bend any pages set it down on that
brown set it down don't get it wet
don't get it wet
all of the and your favorite and the the
dad wouldn't have noticed any of that
probably unless it was on top as long as
you didn't put it back on top
oh if you put on that on top it's done
that the whole mission is done
then you blame it on your friend your
friend did it yeah he did it
and then the dad's like oh my friend my
son is a piece of [ __ ] yeah
your son is yeah because i had no idea
about these magazines which ones
jugs what is it about milk yeah what
about gallons of milk
is it instacart what are you talking
about
i cleaned my son's bed i had to throw
his bed away he's had this bed
by the way theo you don't have kids
right no i don't have any kids man i
would like to have a kid though i'm
putting that out there man
nice you're gonna love it by the way
really oh it's the greatest thing in the
world
having a kid the saddest part is when
they get
old or older they want to throw things
away
and it's like you're throwing your heart
in the garbage
so my son wanted to like rearrange his
room he's had this room
you know there's michael jordan stuff
everywhere it's bad it's it's you know
it's from
from six to you know whatever he's got
all these things that i bought to
and now it's just in the way because now
he's into making beats so he wants to
clear
yeah you want yeah you want that fang
yeah man and i'm telling you i was
crying on the inside but i'm not showing
him any emotion i'm just like yeah throw
it
yep yeah let's scoot that out man get
that out of here man let's [ __ ] get
yeah yeah let's get you
a little peep a chair yeah yeah but i'm
crying it kills me bro but anyways
so i bought him this uh uh what is it
called tempur-pedic mattress bed
whatever oh yeah that's right
but it's a it's a sofa bed so it looks
like a red
sofa but when you open it it's
tempur-pedic it's an amazing
hideaway couch yeah so it makes it like
that it's amazing like if you when you
lay on it it doesn't feel like
one of those regular couch beds it feels
like a bed he's had it forever but my
son's sick of it
right he wants it out so we got rid of
it damn
bro the mayhem that's underneath
this bed because there was no way you
could move this it was so massive
when we finally got the guys to move it
and we all looked at the ground
and i'm like joe like a time capsule bro
what was it like all kind of it was
socks oh it was
uh did it feel seaming kleenex did have
a seam in his vibe everything
everything everything was a dna episode
everything was like a uh
uh what was that like a csi episode
it was just everywhere i took pictures
of it video
drew a chalk out line around his sock oh
you suck yeah
just billions dead murder this is a mass
murder
dude i can't believe and this is
something that's probably obtuse but
something that's coming soon is that
think of all of the val the
nutritional and value that it's in semen
if you really think about it yeah those
[ __ ]
and people are just just tossing it aw
dude bro it's people
have some [ __ ] ruffles you know what
i'm saying like the total
opposite some douches bro
you have you actually have the the
the you actually have the ingredients
to make a human and you [ __ ] throw it
on the floor
and just grab a drumstick and you're
just you're trying to get the chocolate
from the bottom of the cone
you still have a little seed on your
hands oh yeah
praise god brother what are we monsters
and we don't give a [ __ ] bro no
oh dude they had this big guy who used
to jerk off and he would bring it on the
bus and throw it at the kids when the no
he didn't
yeah this big red fellow this big ginger
guy
you know sometimes uh your uh stories
are so fast
yeah and so uh uh there's so much detail
that like you people don't know if
you're lying or not oh i'm not lying man
i'll tell you
are you telling the truth all the time
i'm telling the truth probably 95
percent of the time and 92
these are amazing stories dude and this
handicap kid would always try to catch
it from him all the time which is the
craziest part
see i don't know if that's the
embellishment uh-uh it's real
dude this kid got they what was the
handicapped kid's name they yeah i don't
know his full name but his nickname was
thundercat tj
thundercat johnson dude and they and he
would try and catch semen out of the air
he didn't know it was semen he just
thought it was candy thought it was a
buddy he thought it was a parade
he would like pretend like there were
bands coming he was out there man so so
the the red guy
would jerk off in his hand toss it
and then in super slo-mo thundercat oh
yeah would just
and he had a really chariots of fire
music he had that chris carter on him he
had some hands on him i wouldn't say
that
and he would he sometimes you could have
a grab he would grab something he'd
catch enough
i tell you that he'd catch enough to
probably feel good about himself
but that's the crazy thing you know it's
like
you know one man's trash is another
man's treasure yeah whatever they say
yeah yeah and that's that's good product
right there oh
but think about the fact that we're just
like you know
people are going to the store and
getting all of this macadamian oyster
yeah you know cream for your and all of
it and everybody's just
meanwhile their three kids in the back
of the house are just blowing
through yeah the best salve that god
ever made you know
this will get rid of wrinkles yeah you
know what's crazy i was watching
something on it's elbows but i feel like
we're almost there
no i was watching something on ellen and
sandra bullock was on
and and she and ellen was like why don't
you tell the uh people why your face is
so
beautiful and tight and then they said
it was from like
kids uh when they get sick
no the circumcision oh that breast meat
they said that that's in the inside the
the the makeup that she uses
what and that's why we're going to hell
man
that's are you kidding me oh
that hurts me that
that hurts me man thinking about that
they're cutting it off of people
sometimes adults too
that means there's a back end business
to the the snipping like he he's like
you know this is good for your kid
and you know this will be cleaner for
that area so i'll cut it off for this
much and then he charges them and then
when he gets to his hand he runs through
the back door
i got two yeah i got two i got two like
one two i got two
of these i got two o-rings who needs two
who needs two o-rings
who needs two of that freaking uh who
wants that nine-month calamari huh yeah
extraction
from a a piece of skin
that came from they're doing it to this
one so they don't get ripped off
um far far away and they somehow figured
out how to extract
it's foreskin from a korean baby that's
right there you go
and you know what's the saddest oh what
and they're saying that nonchalant like
what and i'll ask you since you closer
to this really element is
why would koreans be more likely to give
it up
why is that i my best my best friend was
korean he he wasn't circumcised
i don't know why i just told you that
maybe he didn't want to sell it anyway
he passed away
no not not not him he's still like but
his brother did how did you know that
i don't know man how did you know that
you sounded like he passed away when you
first started talking oh no no he just
uh he held on to his uh
his meat yeah i wonder why
i wonder why that
they went korean how do you get that i
don't why did they go karaoke i'll tell
you this a brother ain't giving it up
that's out the gate dude you tell a
brother we're gonna carve a little bit
of your meat off
bro and they're the ones who can spare
it yeah meanwhile they're hitting
up a korean guy who's got the freaking
11th pinky out here
and they [ __ ] chopping off 30 percent
on him bro
damn you got to cut that thing off i'm
gonna make cufflinks out of it
right here now we're going out to you
honey yeah that's the move
those are nice cufflinks what is that
that's me yeah that's
me make your face nice and tight keep
you young [ __ ]
oh yeah let's keep we got a question
right here from a beautiful couple right
here let's hear what they have to say no
yo from one cajun
asian couple to another
what are y'all what asian
type do you think is the sexiest
[Music]
gang buzz buzz wow gang let me think
about that what type is the sexiest
and you're pinoy you're full pinoy yeah
yeah well no i'm half
okay half white half filipino praise god
blood praise god
um um yeah i i you know i'm biased man
i'm gonna have to say filipino
yeah you know my son's mommy was
filipino
yeah yeah you got to say that you know i
like the mix too i like i like the mixed
babies so i like i like a little bit of
white with a little filipino yeah i like
that
oh yeah like an asian with like a hazel
eye it's like wow yeah that happened
like a teriyaki salmon
yeah that's good right i think so yeah
it's more like alaska but it's japanese
yeah
i like that japanese alaskan that's good
[ __ ] right yeah it's like when you see a
white guy doing the uh the limbo you
know
yeah and he's good like his toes moving
forward
like where the [ __ ] he where did you
learn that sir
don't worry about it man it was a cruise
it was a cruise
don't tell your mother your mama
dude there's something about like the
white dad that crushes the luau that
just
saves the family yeah he gets like like
like free pineapple
or whatever for the for the whole table
and he's a king dude yeah he's like but
he was like it wasn't
good but it was so funny yeah but it was
good enough for them and he didn't know
any better he doesn't know and they got
pictures
yeah we all remember that oh i remember
going to the beach man and we got uh
and you know we'd go out there and we'd
steal some liquor during the day and go
bury it in the sand and then go get it
back at night like uh
you know like turtles do yeah and so
then we dig it up at night and go drink
it and then we'd meet up with strangers
on the beach strange women
i met this girl that was in the wicken
one time witchcrafter
and me and she wasn't into it she was in
it she was doing it she was literally
walking on the beach in the middle of
the night
no man at age 15 dude and we i don't
know what we did but
we did something man that is always the
creepiest story and
especially on the receiving end as a kid
it's a cool story
but when you're a father and your kids
come back from the beach
saying that [ __ ] because my son did it
in in maui
they came running back in they're like
oh we met some dudes on the beach i'm
like
what the [ __ ] what do they look like
like well you don't hang out with dudes
at the beach
no they were cool dad no they're no they
weren't yeah
no man homeless talking to 15 year old
kids is cool at the beach
that's true man dude when i think back
because when i we had this fellow named
richard langenstein and
and the the listeners know this and this
fellow was con eventually
convicted or semi-convicted pedophile
and but when i was young he was just
this cool guy
that we went to smoke weed with and
would buy steaks yeah did you fall
asleep a lot huh did you fall asleep
around this guy yeah there's a couple of
half memories that i have that i don't
want to
read all the way through yeah yeah don't
go through i don't want to read the
second half of the book
but he was but at the time we thought it
was so cool that he would
he drove one of my friends to vegas for
the weekend right like pretty sketchy
right there right there cute religious
brother accused of molesting student
but this was after and you knew him oh
yeah dude
i used to smoke weed with that fella man
he was a teacher at our school man
he was a teacher i introduced him like
half of my friends
so here's what i didn't realize man i
was a freaking like a like a penis mule
for this guy you know what i'm saying
yeah you're bringing him in
yeah it is because i met him at school
he was a substitute teacher you were
like that girl on smallville
allison mack yeah yeah i was a recruiter
she'd be serving 120 years right now
theo free gillane dude
um but anyway but at the time it's so
crazy at the time how i thought oh it's
so cool it's so normal
i'm just i'm lucky we met this cool guy
yeah now when i think about it
okay if at 40 i'm smoking weed with a 15
year old
yeah i'm not doing no man
it would be insane to do that that's it
doesn't even make sense
no it's so wild how from the other side
of the
that's what i'm saying it's so clear
when mike wants
you got to remember i'm taking
responsibility of all my nephews
oh like i've told the their parents i
got it don't worry they're going to be
safe and they come
running back into the into the the house
and they're like
yo we met these dudes man they're so
coming what
duncan took a hit like my oldest cut my
oldest nephew took a hit i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah what
are you guys doing what's going on
why would you do that yeah who are these
guys he just
disappeared yeah duncan got his nails
done by some guy
yeah i feel weird if i hang out with
gianni he's only 24. yeah that's a good
point
that's eight years does it feel weird
fifteen yeah yeah man
if uh if i get a dm or anything like
that it's always like hey man
uh thank you so much kid yeah tell your
mom and dad i said hi
i swear to god i i don't i
mean hey tell your father
mr coy says thank you
all right man do your homework it's
sketchy now especially dude hell no
i'll ask a girl straight up if they're
going to try to me too me or not yeah
you should
yeah just so i have it in writing
yeah you know yeah that's good like wait
this girl was me to me and
said she wasn't gonna meet yeah wait a
minute you said clearly you weren't
yeah what yeah what's going on here
but i'm gonna go through let me think
nick dat's an asian girl too
vietnamese girl oh vietnamese they're
nice
oh yeah they're not they're firecrackers
yeah she's she keeps me alive
they've been they've been through a lot
yeah they've been through a lot
oh yeah so uh yeah you gotta watch her
you better watch your back on that one
her parents came by boat
wow yeah well yeah a lot of them did
they didn't stayed in hong kong for a
while
oh yeah and a vietnamese person they
could sleep on a damn in a client
on a rack of a car i saw i saw a
vietnamese person fall asleep on a whole
thing of cans
unbelievable just recycled cancer
beautiful every turn was just
and didn't wake him up just
you can't [ __ ] with me my next-door
neighbor was vietnamese and he was the
[ __ ] man talk [ __ ] had the thickest
accent yeah
and was in my face when we played ball
man you can't call me dude [ __ ] you dude
his name was v by the way v
every vietnamese person's name v and he
had hair just like you oh yeah
this is 1983 man he had this tight sides
and then the long he's like no [ __ ] you
do
take that take that dude yeah i do
he was that's where i got my accent from
when i do the vietnamese accent it's
always b
oh that's oh he was so funny man is she
funny is she funny
she's hilarious yeah i i don't know what
it is about i i think
theo when it's when you get like uh like
like when when
military presence is is there
like does this make sense like the
philippines has a lot of military oh
yeah
back in the day and i think they absorb
that culture
and that lifestyle and they and they get
uh
you know when you tell a joke they get
it right you know what i mean does that
make sense like i think so because they
probably were like
all that a lot of what they probably saw
was a lot of american stuff
yeah and they hear american humor and
the way they talk and like the little
words that we use and and they get it
does that make sense
to translate it huh vietnamese are
gangsters oh they're
gangster they're like they're gangster
business people like louisiana has one
of the largest populations of vietnamese
in uh
in the us we have the only vietnamese um
person in the house of representatives
the only vegan did not know that
is uh louisiana because all the fishing
industry
so they come down there hunting shrimp
and they stay did not know that
huang joseph he goes by joseph chow
of course he does dude but would that be
pronounced cow
cow joseph cow joseph cow that's a good
call bet it would
my girlfriend helped secure two pounds
of weed for boosie badass yeah we had to
pay busy badass and weed when he showed
up that's
beautiful that's a beautiful thing
that's a great thing but that's a beats
man they'll get you anything you need
tables you need a wedding
yeah and they don't give a [ __ ] if the
order's wrong have you ever seen that
yeah vietnamese don't give a [ __ ] when i
ask every time for my pho
that's vietnamese right and i and in
fact this just happened we can call my
son to verify this this damn story
and uh once again i asked no cilantro i
can't stand cilantro it [ __ ] up every
meal
and i go please no cilantro no problem
no cilantro boom [ __ ] cilantro damn
i go to cilantro no green okay and just
walked off
okay okay yeah
okay well you want me to put my hand in
there yeah
oh yeah because it doesn't really go in
huh one by one [ __ ]
i don't know man yeah there's something
more like i don't know we got
white culture gets so a little bit too
proper over time
yeah and a lot of these cultures that
have had a lot more of a rot gut
experience or a tougher
upcoming in the past 100 years they
really
there's so much more humor bro bro i
love how you describe that that's so
true
man so much more humor how'd you say
that rut gutted
rot good rot gut yeah that's so true man
like when you when you go through just
[ __ ] and you're only your only form of
entertainment is yourself
yeah right oh and you can only be funny
and make fun of yourself man
that's that's why they are who they are
man like that's why filipinos are like
that it's just
that's our form of entertainment when
you're broke and you don't have any
money and
you depend on the family to to be the
entertainment at the party
yeah right like i don't know that made
sense how you said that
no i think look when you look at a lot
of culture that's where a lot of humor
really comes out of you know is uh
is some type of not turmoil really but
just
i think a place of unrest or not having
something where be
where you need to become an instrument
as a person you need to become
funny or become because it's not there
there's not the other elements that you
have to get the entertainment exactly so
it's like unless
somebody's gonna go rent a vhs you know
which somebody has the money to do once
a week
yep then otherwise somebody's gonna have
to start entertaining yeah someone's
gonna juggle [ __ ]
somebody's gotta juggle dude so grab
those three balls and do something
parties in two days that's it yeah
that's the truth man
i think there's something about that but
yeah i'm gonna go through and rank now
japanese i've and i've
you know i've long been you know i'm not
a i'm not anti-japanese yeah
but they're i get no japanese person
it's hard to know if they care
what's going on living to see it's just
like
all right you know i never i can't tell
if they've just come from a fire
or if they just got a massage like i
just oh you mean their expression i have
no idea
yeah never
like i went to a japanese a buddy of my
married japanese girl was at the wedding
i was like dude are you sure this girl
would like
you like i have zero vibe off of this
really yeah just correct and i think
it's just because if you don't grow up
around a certain population you have
just have no idea what their experiences
are like
that's true like filipinos a lot easier
china's they're more gangsters bro
china's really like the black community
of asia really chinese people are funny
too by the way chinese
people chinese people don't care if they
die bro you'll be walking down the
street with like in
shanghai somebody dies they make a soup
out of them
put a sign up what the [ __ ] bro
sell [ __ ] whatever his name was you
know him key soup and it's a [ __ ]
funeral lunch and then done and
everybody goes back to work bro
those people keep it moving yeah they
don't have time they don't have time bro
there's 1.9 billion theo
it don't matter you know what i mean
when when one drops it's like
you get to open your arms just a little
bit more you have to do a full stretch
three more die yeah oh this is so bad
there's a sinkhole yeah oh you [ __ ]
finally you can get a knife
yeah they're like
the chinese and it's not like we have
the luxury of having a little bit of
space over here
yeah you know we have a lot of space
yeah i'm so sick of people going
man it's we're so overpopulated i'm like
have you ever
flown from l.a to to
to vegas yeah you see all that land
you ever you ever fly from like omaha
to what's the next state over cincinnati
maybe
cincinnati you ever go to st louis to
denver yeah
it's land look at all that land what the
[ __ ] are you guys
talking about man it is only populated
wherever you
live yeah oh man there's so many people
in los angeles
yeah yeah yeah yeah go to victorville
yeah go to
go to needles go to needles you ever fly
from
san antonio to dallas it's ridiculous
yeah so much land oh yeah so much land
stop it
we got we got room there's not enough
people
i think more people are starting to
spread out now especially yeah i think
during
especially now during this whole pandy a
lot of people were like hey i got a
i don't know what this rat race is that
i'm stuck in i want to go see
about being a human being you know yeah
i think like places like utah
are getting busier um you know also
states without
taxes you know without state taxes are
getting busier too oh
way busier you know uh i'm in vegas now
so yeah how is that good
i love it i got a house in vegas and i
mean i have a house here
right but i i vegas is where i like to
go i'm always in vegas
you should go to vegas you know what i
would i'll i would consider it i think
i'm gonna try nashville for a little
while yeah but then i would consider
vegas
yeah the reason why i like vegas so much
it's a it's an hour flight man
yeah you know you go to nashville was
that two and a half oh it's more it's
like three and a half hours
yeah see that's that's a that's an event
yeah that's a lot of planning
whereas like you live in vegas you're
living your life and it's like hey we
need you to do so
i'll be there and i'll be there at six
yeah that is cool you know what i mean
it is pretty cool at 11 am you could
have a call
and decide you need to be there the next
morning and at 5 00 p.m you could take a
flight and beat it but
done fresh and ready the next day yeah
that's one thing one thing that's nice
about nashville is the proximity like
you can drive to you want to go perform
in huntsville
it's two hours away you want to perform
in indianapolis it's four hours away
you want to perform in cincinnati it's
four hours away
like you just don't really realize how
many places
you could just go do comedy yeah that
are within you know
yeah you could just you know get on a
plane at 11
and and be at your hotel by 2 p.m i love
nashville by the way it's cool man it's
interesting
it's completely different oh it's
completely different yeah it's it's like
uh
it's like a western version of new york
yeah like when new york was like that
big jazz movement
and entertainment movement you know am i
making any sense
back in the day you could just go to new
york and everyone was playing jazz music
everywhere and like jazz was huge
i wasn't from that era i just heard this
story from cosby
i see it in you know like movies and and
just like
man i wish i lived during that time yeah
go to these clubs and all of a sudden
this
their musicians were just playing and
and like you know what i mean
and you hear all these stories like and
then all of a sudden you see
i go to nashville and it was the same
thing yeah it was
it was like i was seeing i don't like
country but when i'm in nashville i love
country yeah because i see it i see
those stories come to life that
that whole jazz movement in new york i'm
seeing it in nashville i'm walking
every bar there's someone playing
someone's playing you know i went to a
brunch and there was a band play i got
off the plane there was a band play i
bought cds
i still say this every time i have the
cd from the gin sisters
i don't know if they made it or if they
became big look them up uh their name
their name jyn sisters and i got off my
plane in nashville
and they huge crowd wrapped around them
all they had was a speaker an amplifier
and two i think two sisters i hope
they're sisters
uh and they were playing bought their cd
and i was like and and that's what
live music is and that's what that whole
yeah there's a lot of love when you're
hungry when someone's hungry you know
you you buy into that
there's that energy you know when you
see someone just i'm in an airport plane
it's like yeah man
i'll buy that what is it i'll buy it i
love it i support it yeah
what about this do you find that it's
tougher to
um recreate that
desire as you achieve more success and
stuff
no you don't no i don't wow i don't
i'm i'm still thinking of things that i
need to do
well i'm still thinking of things that i
need to do yeah and it burns inside me
like i can't wait
wow mm-hmm i'm working on this project
right now i don't sleep
really yeah yeah man fire
like i'm on fire right now you're up for
an emmy right now aren't you
uh it was a uh it was a people's choice
award wow
yeah for that for that special and that
special that i shot in the philippines
was
burning inside of me for years
and for it to come to life the way it
did i was so i was so excited i don't
know
i could never explain it to someone what
that special meant to me because
you know we live in a time now where you
get to watch
you get to go online and see whoever it
is that that you are like
you know if you're if you're vietnamese
you can go online and and find
vietnamese entertainment
all kinds of singers whatever right but
try doing that in 1982 and try and find
a filipino that looked like me doing
stand-up
yeah when you only had three channels to
go from you know people thought you were
sinbad's son a lot of you yeah a lot of
people
thought i was uh something they didn't
know what i was by the way
because i was a mixed kid i was a
military kid so you know i had the hazel
eyes but then they were like
asian looking like people always ask me
what are you what but uh
anyways what i'm getting at is just like
that's what that whole thing was like
being able to create something to help
inspire
other kids that are trying to get into
this business you know oh i can only
imagine something like that what that
will do that fuse
you know like um i just remember the
first time i've ever even went and saw
stand-up comedy i didn't even know you
could do it
i'd never i know my brother had like
gotten the videos of eddie murphy and
stuff but
i didn't know i wasn't they wouldn't
even know there was like a club thing
yeah they wouldn't let me come watch
those with them
yeah so i would just hear about it um
and i would see uh living color
yeah but i was in college and somebody
took me to the comedy club and there was
a man up there i think it was mark gross
do you remember him i remember mark ross
um great joke writer and he's just up
there telling jokes and i'm like
this is a job this is insane yeah
um loved it and yeah and it just blew my
mind that that was
the real thing but i could only and that
was probably where the seed comes from
so i can only imagine if you're sitting
in the philippines you know
i wanted to go to the philippines with
it i wanted to be able to show the world
like you know this is the culture i'm
talking about these are our people they
speak
english you know i mean the best people
dog
i've been to the azores islands over
there um
was this it let's hear it
what's this this is uh theo was asked
who what person would he say
it's related uh which person would he
send to
uh be an ambassador to the aliens
and this is factual right here's
documented information probably a
filipino dude i'm really infatuated by
filipinos
they're happy they're joyous you know
they call them smiling people somewhere
on the internet
and um and every filipino i meet they're
real gracious they do a lot of senior
care centers hospice
so you don't [ __ ] who else you're
gonna send out there dude
you know what i'm saying i love it drunk
you know what
i need that video can you send me that
video that's true man
oh i gotta put filipinos a lot and what
a lot of people don't realize is
before you die a lot of the last person
a lot of people see is a filipino person
man so true so true
that's pretty fascinating when you think
about that when you think about whatever
scope of god's world that it is
that that is the last i don't care if
you're white or black or whoever
there's a pretty decent chance it's
going to be a filipino housekeeper
you're going to a housekeeper house
yeah or someone yeah that works in care
yeah nursing yes
that's so true man so many nurses that's
crazy yeah
i wonder if that starts to wear i wonder
what effect that has on the culture over
time if it has any you know
none wow it is literally a part of their
dna
like like i said earlier man when you
have absolutely nothing like
when you actually go to the philippines
and visit it and and and you realize
holy [ __ ] man i'm spoiled i need to shut
up
i need to really not talk when i
you know what i mean like i you go there
and you see these kids barefoot and
and i remember we were shooting
something and this brought a tear to my
eye we were shooting something
because i wanted to show the guys uh
just like these monuments right
and and there was this woman that was
you know she had a cart and she's
selling
you know you know fried food right and
uh
and then her kid barefoot and everything
uh after we bought the food she takes
his clothes off and just gives him a
bath right there
oh yeah full on back with a soda with a
soda with mountain dew
oh yeah no but like like full-on shot
and the kid's happy as hell
oh yeah and she's bathing with soap and
everything a
cup of water puts it dries them off
clothes back on he takes off running
it's just another day for this kid
yeah but when i saw that i was like holy
[ __ ] man
that's life that's real life so it's
like what do you do
what do you do to get out of that right
you try and learn to speak english
right you got to learn to speak english
and then you got to become a nurse why
because everyone needs a nurse yeah
everyone needs a nurse just like you
said
you got to make yourself yeah yeah you
got to be of need yeah and and
who else do you get someone that's
willing to do it
you know someone that speaks english and
i need to get out of this situation so
yeah i'll take care of him
it's on his last day yeah i'll i'll be
there wow i'll make sure that
his or hers last days are the best last
days ever
it's pretty interesting man because yeah
it's a lot of i wonder how many people
in their lives have been racist or had
racist thoughts you know especially
and even if they weren't their own they
learned them or whatever and
and then they're laying on their death
bed or whatever and the person that's
there usually that's what's
that's what's crazy about life man yeah
the person that's there usually
is probably of another ethnicity yeah
you know that's so weird i never even
thought of that
theo that's so deep bro it's just
interesting about that
you're just laying there and like and
life just moves on
and you have to at that point you have
to inside of yourself think like man i
have to
i can't be hateful because i need this
person yeah
you know even if i just need them just
to be the last person that's
there when i'm gone when i leave just
hook me up with a little bit of morphine
before i go
yeah just say yeah or something just
tell whoever comes in the room that i
was a decent person i was a decent
i was a decent man i was a decent man
yeah yeah
wow i never even thought of that look
there's no secret
there's no secret that americans have
been overpaying for car insurance
in other countries you might get car
insurance thirty dollars six sixteen
dollars
mexico but in america it's been reported
that americans
are overpaying on car insurance
by over 21 billion dollars
yep that's americans but
searching for a better deal can take
hours so that's why we don't do it
and it usually results in a barrage of
unwanted spam
calls and emails and other they may
literature [ __ ] literature
until now thanks to thezebra.com
the zebra.com is the nation's leading
car insurance
comparison site because it's the only
place you can get
side by side quotes from over 100
providers
and choose the best for you in 90
seconds or less
and they'll never sell you information
sometimes you see somebody they come
running up to you hey hey is this your
name
do you live at this place and you don't
even know him
and that's because they bought you
information off somebody behind a
building
techcrunch calls the zebra kayak for
auto insurance
how much can you save on car and home
insurance
go today and start saving at the
zebra.com
t-h-e-o that's the zebra
dot com slash t-h-e-o spelled
t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a
dot com slash theo go save
if it's time to quit it's time to quit
and i'm not talking about masturbatory
activities at the moment i'm talking
more
about nicotine thankfully
lucy nicotine is a company founded by
cal tech scientists
and former smokers looking for a better
and cleaner
nicotine alternative researched and
developed for three years
to be made for people not patients
lucy has created a nicotine gum with
four milligrams of nicotine
that come in three flavors wintergreen
cinnamon pomegranate
lucy also has a lozenge with four
milligrams of nicotine
in cherry ice flavor oh she's sexy
each and every flavor actually tastes
great
it's 20 20 get rid of your cigarettes
unplug your vape
throw out your dip and get some lucy
nicotine
gum or lozenges this is the real deal
i quit smoking seven months ago and i
feel great
i can uh you know i could blow up a
balloon or something for the children at
a party
and i don't have to be sad about it if
this isn't for you it might be for
someone else in your family
a grandparent or somebody a uncle or
even just a
shady character that comes around to
smoke
that's right it's the real deal a
subscription to lucy comes directly to
your door
each month and you don't have to leave
your house because lucy has delivery
down
that's right go to lucy.co and use promo
code theo at checkout
that's lucy.co use promo code
theo if if you're trying to quit this is
a good way to try
feel good about yourself lucy.co promo
code theo
it's pretty interesting man we got a
white fella right here who's obviously
likes the lakers and we're excited to
have him
what up theo what up joseph body by
bourbon here
i knew from back in the day on chelsea
handler as one of the panel you were
hilarious
i was just wondering if you missed doing
those shows or do you enjoy doing stand
up more
the uh mafungo skit with the cool whip
container
as a child is easily one of the funniest
things i've ever heard
no one ever wanted to trade for those
doritos or oreos man it's a shame
or got a cuban rest shot not a lot of
mafunga was sold that day
other than that gang gang oh that's nice
he's just a fan huh that's awesome i i
you know i
miss chelsea i was doing stand-up before
chelsea
but uh i i always tell people um she was
the new johnny carson
you know when johnny waved you over to
the seat that meant you made it
yeah and i felt the same way with
chelsea if she invited you to that pound
you
you slayed man you made it like they
came to see you
wow i was so nervous that one time i
went yeah man
too nervous i couldn't handle it i
didn't really yeah i think i was never a
big chelsea fan
and then it was just uh it was just i
was just
nervous it was like the only thing going
on for a lot of comedians yeah
you know i mean you guys were like top
of the he you know you guys were
you guys were getting on television
every week you know every day
every day we were every single day we
were on which was crazy
they thought we were a cast people
thought we were a cast
i felt like i was on a prime time sitcom
that's how i felt
it was crazy that's why yeah it was it
was nuts man people were coming
out for those shows man i was always so
uptight and then i was
i just was not a chelsea fan so i just i
think that made me nervous
she was kind of intimidating that made
me nervous i was just kind of nervous at
that time yeah i think i just wasn't
being myself really you know i was like
all right how do i look am i okay
does my you know is every are my eyes
open like just thinking about all these
other things yeah just being fun but did
you
here's a cool question did you did you
know who you were
yet like i feel like and it's just me
talking i feel like when you started
doing
after your last special and then you hit
the pod right after the last special
yeah i felt like that's when theo became
theo yeah like i feel like your voice
really just
like cut right through after that i feel
like
during chelsea i think you were still in
that stage of i'm funny
but i i don't know am i right yeah
totally i i don't know what i am i don't
know what i'm doing
i'm trying to be like a white guy that
could be on a sitcom yeah i just didn't
know what
i was doing yeah you knew you were funny
i was afraid to be myself i think
you know i was afraid you know there's
not a lot of acceptance of southern
style comedians really
there's not a lot of southern since the
blue collar tour there's not even
and i don't consider myself a southern
comedian but i don't think anyone does
they don't have that they just haven't
really taken anybody from our area even
yeah so like i don't even like that that
label
by the way to be honest like i don't
like it when people
i would never want to lay like i would
never label theo as a southern comic
yeah you're just a comedian
and you're really [ __ ] funny um just
like when people go oh
funny asian american it's like bro i'm
just a comedian man
yeah you know i mean like there's no
difference from
me and you we're we're funny for what we
talked about yeah you know what i mean
and
and you know i think there are different
genres of comedy
you know i mean there's a puppeteer and
then there's a dancer and then there's a
magician and there's
political and there's all kinds of [ __ ]
that you can you can separate us by
yeah but we're storytellers man we're
just
we're comics that tell our stories yeah
i like that that's a good point
yeah i never really felt into that space
kind of but i think i always felt like i
had to fight this label or something i
think a lot of the war was in may
possibly even in my own head you know
but yeah
um no it was you were right because i
felt the same way with me
i felt like i don't understand why you
guys are making me fight for this it's
obvious i'm funny
yeah so that's why i love chelsea so
much because she saw it right away when
you know i used to open for john lovitz
and then did i tell you this story
no i didn't so i used to open for john
lovitz at the laugh factory and
this is when i'm cleaning yachts and
selling shoes at nordstrom rack
everywhere i was going to northrack and
i look at my phone it's just a number
and it's
and i answered and it's like hi it's
john levitt and i'm freaking out because
i used to impersonate him in school
you know what i mean the liar and all
that stuff you know all those jokes yeah
yeah and then uh and then here he is
actually on my phone
he's like i i really i've been watching
you at the laugh factory and
i really want you to open for me you'd
be hysterical
i'm doing a show i'm doing a show every
wednesday night
love it's wednesdays or some [ __ ] i
don't know love it or not
i'm trying to make [ __ ] up and then uh
so i was like yeah and i started doing
these shows with them
and next you know this is a true story
you're gonna love this this is such a
[ __ ]
weird thing you ready nick i don't know
if i told you this story
but he goes he goes i'm gonna start i'm
gonna start
this is so funny i'm gonna start putting
this uh
lady on the show her name is chelsea
handler
she's so funny she's my only friend on
myspace
what the [ __ ] he goes when you go home
go to your myspace she's my only friend
her
and tom and i went home and it was
literally
tom and her and that's when i found out
who chelsea was and she started doing
these shows
and after every show she would talk so
much [ __ ]
so while john's on stage she's just
talking [ __ ] and then she was like
i want you to be my sidekick i got this
show idea and we're
pitching the show and uh and i want you
to be my sidekick
and so i was pretty much supposed to be
chewy
wow yeah and and then uh and then i
turned it down
but we went through all kinds of like
you know like like meetings they weren't
like full-on production meetings but it
was like ideas and
going through the meetings and getting
ready for the pitch and then finally i
was just like uh
i go hey chelsea i called her on the
phone i was like yeah
i just i really want to be my guy like i
don't want to be a sidekick i'm trying
to find
this i want to do my own special i want
to blah blah and she cursed me out bro
damn it's like oh good luck with that
[ __ ] [ __ ] watch this bubble and she
just cursing me out
she's like this show is gonna be a
[ __ ] hit you made the wrong [ __ ]
decision and then she hangs up the phone
i'm just like
huh and six months later chelsea
lately is just blowing up wow and i'm at
nordstrom rack
and i remember my ex-wife picking me up
and uh while she's driving me home she's
like
i'm recording the show right now we got
to get home this this lady chelsea
handler
she's so funny i've seen it and i'm like
that's the [ __ ] show i was supposed
to be on
dang and uh and i remember i was so
depressed
and uh wondering why you know why i said
no to it and uh
for six months i didn't get a call from
and then finally she called me
but but anyways what i was getting at
like i felt i feel like i'm always
fighting to tell people i'm funny yeah
chelsea was the only one that
said yes and and it was funny because it
was just like
comedy central's passing on me abc
turned me down
you know i got on this one pilot they
fired me and it's just like
like what is going on why don't i have
an hour yet like i don't understand why
i don't have an hour i'm crushing on the
road right now why don't i have an hour
so
yeah i feel you man i just like what is
it that you're not getting is it because
you guys don't get it because
the country gets it right but why aren't
you guys getting it so
wow did you feel that way when you were
shooting your [ __ ]
yeah i mean i guess i felt i started to
get upset like you go into a lot of
rooms
in l.a and it's a lot of the same person
when you go
in there yeah whether or not the
industry wants to really admit it i feel
like
it's always it's usually like a really
liberal person it's just
and that's fine it's just always the
same person yeah
so it's like at a certain point i'm like
well
how can any of these people have any cl
like yeah at a certain point there's
just too much of the same
they're just looking through too much of
a similar lens even yeah if they don't
just like if i went into a place and it
was
all um like redneck
women or something at a certain point
i'd be like this is just too
there's too much of a monopoly on the
point of view yeah exactly at a certain
point it's just like i'm just like a
salmon but the water's too thick man
it's just like
this you know and it made me feel like
but it also made me feel like really
unwanted it made me feel
so i felt and it made me mad because it
was like man i
you know you're supposed to you're
telling me i'm supposed to come out of
my small town and get to hollywood and
this is where you can make it and this
is
but then i get there and it's like you
don't want any nobody like me you don't
want anybody like me yeah
and i think it was also like around um
i mean i think i kind of made my switch
for things like right around
like the last election and it was like
um
like somebody wrote a article about my
special where it was like uh
oh this guy would be a perfect this is
the trump's perfect special
you know and it's like don't you see
this is a character this is like
yeah don't you have any satire like what
a [ __ ] idiot right yeah
you know like it just i don't know man i
just felt so turned off by such a
a industry that was supposed to be
welcoming to everybody
and then it felt like oh not everybody
yeah not everybody you're
you're so right and then and then they
put you in that oh there you are
yeah and then i already have a favorite
stand-up comedian
uh he may find his kindred spirit in
theovonne and that's just [ __ ] i mean
what an [ __ ]
this guy's long been a shitty writer
yeah i mean he doesn't have a career and
then you know what else don't shout this
guy out by the way and then uh
you know what i mean like you shouldn't
even put it up because you you just
you're giving them energy yeah which is
stupid because obviously this guy is
desperate
and he was always desperate and he would
always write about like the super like
schumer he would always
and they would always make fun of him
behind his back that was the craziest
thing yeah i've always been like oh he's
such a loser
and he's meanwhile just peddling to
write whatever article yeah
i'm like just the whole industry kind of
made me a little bit sick but that's
when i started doing podcasting and
that's like when tfatk had me on yeah um
rogan had me on you guys had me on over
there when you were working at corolla
studios yeah you crushed um
just different and that's when you found
it right yeah that's when i was like oh
i'm just going to talk about stuff that
i know about i'm just going to talk
about just my life
and you know what you know you know
what's cool is like as as much as that
pisses me off right
but i'm kind of glad that that happened
yeah you know what i mean especially
with netflix like i told you the story
right i had to pay for it yeah you had
to do your own
yeah and like i did not understand why i
had to pay for my own special
like i remember backstage after i i
taped the first show
me and my agent my manager and i'm just
like this is so unfair like i was so mad
like this is this is [ __ ]
like i don't get it like oh it would
have made me mad yeah because it's like
you know cause say oh by the way they
already said
when i when i said i was shooting in
seattle uh they made sure to call and go
hey we just want you guys to know
we don't we're not interested like they
really wanted to make sure that we
knew that so like just imagine the
pressure bro
and like and my son's laying on the
couch in the green room i'm broke
after this special i'm i'm done all the
money that i saved up done
and then i was just like this is
[ __ ] why why do i gotta fight and
sell this
and then they still yeah and then you
have to then you have to put it on their
network how much did they
well here oh hold on i don't want to get
fired from netflix
i love netflix yeah uh don't get me
wrong i
it wasn't their fault right you know
what i mean it's just the uphill we're
talking about it was the uphill it was
the obstacle
they they were they were booked they're
just they were legit they were legit
built
and who's to say who's to say because i
i use this example all the time right
like it's like
you can't get mad at someone that's
responsible for
billions of dollars right right and they
hire certain people like all right you
get you get
50 million i want you to buy a bunch of
talent yo it's their
job to write these checks right and say
my
my special flops which i knew it wasn't
but say it did
they're the ones that get in trouble so
it's like imagine if i had a couple
million dollars and someone goes go find
me some time like
that's a scary job and i get it and i i
do understand that and i know i'm making
excuses but
i'm also happy that they they didn't uh
give me a special because i went and
shot that thing myself and i went on to
shoot three more
on my own for netflix and and the the
two that that i shot after that
they gave me the money like they
literally just gave me the money said
here here we're all in
just you shoot it you did so good on
that first special we don't want to
touch it
yeah they gave me full creative control
wow so it's like
yeah i was [ __ ] up with the obstacle
that they gave me but when i
showed them that i could do it and give
them a good product they bought three
more from me
right so yeah it's so great yeah it's
like you just got to get that scale to
tip you just yeah
and maybe that's what it was with you
maybe it's like yo you keep getting
pushed up against the wall and then
finally you're like yo [ __ ] it i'm right
here
i'll just do it this is what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna do me right here
yeah and then you look what you did now
now everyone's on you
and now we have it yeah now we have a
new special that we're doing with
netflix which is cool but um yeah i feel
you i think it's just like
i don't know sometimes it did just seem
like the journey like the the
the struggle was easier for other people
but but it's like oh man
fear yeah we both know yeah and it
made it it did make this bad because i
i know who you're talking about yeah
it's not fantastic
we came up at the same time yeah so you
and i both saw
you know certain comics and we're not
hating on them
we're not but we just knew that we
there was an obstacle and it wasn't fair
yeah
because i know what you're talking about
because there was i would watch a
special go what the [ __ ]
really [ __ ] really
but i wouldn't go public with it all
right it would be like yo [ __ ] this
oh i always have to bite my tongue but
but i knew it doesn't
yeah but but i knew but i knew my time
was coming
i knew it and if i had to make it then i
had to make it
and i'll still make it dude they gave me
another one by the way they just i just
signed another deal
for my fourth that's crazy and and i'm
ready
and they want me to shoot now and i'm
like no i i know exactly when i'm gonna
shoot it and i know exactly where i'm
going to shoot it
and that's where it's going to be dang
that creative control is so important
right
yeah oh yeah and that's one thing that's
nice about netflix is that they give you
that
yeah um shout out to all of them by the
way i just want to
do that robbie prog neil joanne they
they man robert guillermo yo they
are amazing over at netflix yeah and uh
and yo and i always say that you know i
what i just told you right now i did on
stage in malaysia
right i was doing this huge venue in
malaysia and i and i
told the whole netflix story about how
they didn't give me the
the deal and how i tried to get them to
come down and they kept canceling
you know come to this show i'll i'll fly
you out i even i told my manager i'll
fly them to san francisco
i'll leave the jet running come watch my
set
we'll we'll shuttle them back to the jet
and fly back like i wanted that special
so bad bro
and they kept turning around and i was
like i don't get it like why why don't
you want to see what i'm doing right now
like i was really hurt by it and i was
saying this on stage and then i
you know and then ended the story by
saying hey i shot it myself and then
they bought it from me so what i'm
trying to say is don't let obstacles get
it's like an inspirational story right
yeah and then they were there
and i had no idea that uh one of the
execs was there
and he was in line and he came and you
know the meet and greet and my [ __ ]
heart
fell out of my chest and i'm like
yo i don't want to say his name but uh i
go
i go you know that i you know i i i'm
just telling my side of the story and
you know but as you can tell i gave you
guys love that he was you know you don't
need to explain
he goes i want you to tell that story he
goes please tell that story in fact do
that story on your next special on
netflix
tell that story yeah and i like he was
cool with it and and when he said that i
just hugged him and i was like thank you
i just
you know there was just a lot of
struggle that i was going through a lot
of tears you know what i mean
yeah there's nowhere to put it all a lot
of times i don't know where to put it
except in your work
nobody wants to hear like a lot of the
you know the sob story just doesn't
really there's no real place for it
there never is in the world it's like
all of your what do you think that is
theo what do you think it is that people
don't want to hear the sob story well
it's not even a sob story
it's an it's an emotional story it's
like right it's a grind
like when people hear like what you just
said to me like i didn't know that about
you
i didn't know you were struggling
through that i really didn't i i always
looked at you
as the guy that was like killing it
and it was kind of making me jealous
because i knew i had like at least 10
years on you
yeah you know what i mean but i i never
said that i every time i told you i
praised you
i was posting yours you were always
super
that inspires me like when i see someone
blowing up that inspires me
it's like okay it's possible what is it
that people don't want to hear
is it because they don't want any
motivation do they not want to be
inspired do they like
being where they're at does that make
sense
yeah i think it makes sense that's a
good question man i think
there's i think the motivational side of
it there's there's a place for it
there's a place to share your struggle
there's a place to share what happened
and what it was like in your point of
view
yeah i think what there isn't a lot of
times is
there's no here's what there isn't
there's never
an apology yeah there's never like
and from the industry from whatever your
your idea in our heads of what the
industry is what
there's never like hey i'm i'm sorry we
didn't you know
yeah there's never and i think that
sometimes get like can be
like it's just an unforgiving business
yeah there's no apologies there's no
whatever
you know and and it's in the end it's
just what i've learned about business
that business is just you know like you
said it's somebody in an office
who you know finally robbie came and saw
me downtown
at the wilton and we crushed it and it
was like and he was really great
gracious backstage and like really kind
and like um
and it was different like you know in my
head i'm always thinking like oh these
people don't like me or they don't
you know uh you know and
but all that's just my side of the story
they're just doing business they're not
thinking about me
yeah just thinking about whatever they
have to do that day in their business
like
like anybody else yeah but there's never
an apology that's i think there's never
it's like that about a lot of things in
life like there's never
you know there's never like you're maybe
your dad behaved a certain way when you
were young there's
there's no way to get a like a healing
from it sometimes there's just never a
healing you have to do it all yourself
yeah
you have to like just forgive you know
even if you made the war up in your own
head or whatever you have to forgive you
have to forgive you have to
there's never that moment of like hey we
were wrong
you know i and i don't know if that's
one thing about life that's kind of
tough sometimes
is um you know because i struggle with
my relationship with my mother and i
but at a certain point it's like what am
i going to do hound like you know
she's an older she's getting older now
it's like
all i can do is be forgiving you know
just i may never get whatever it was i
needed her to you know to say or to do
that
[ __ ] may have long sailed you know man
we are the same person man
yeah you're so right about that and it's
hard it's a hard pill to swallow too
it's a hard pill to swallow ego's a
[ __ ] bro
it's scary bro look i want to tell you
that i have been having an issue getting
a
home mortgage loan and refinance
and one of the reasons because i got a
couple of dings on the credit
you know i call experian and say hey boy
you dinged up you banged up son
i i didn't make a couple payments on
time timely payments they say
well thankfully i'm working with a
company called bridge
credit solutions they are different
they are backed with a hundred percent
money back guarantee
for any items they cannot remove that's
right you will not find that anywhere
in the credit repair industry you'll
know exactly what you're paying for at
the beginning of the repair
bridge credit solutions prides itself on
its lightning quick turnaround time
they will guarantee removal of certain
negative
items in as quick as 24 hours
that's right now you will need to have
bridge
credit report access prior to scheduling
your audit
they cannot go over your credit report
without it but that costs just
one dollar they are very personable
and they take credit repairs seriously
you can call or
text no matter the hour go check them
out they're helping me
bridge credit bridgecreditsolutions.com
theo
i see with a lot of these like athletes
too you see them struggling with ego you
know antonio brown and
you know michael thomas is having an
issue this year it seems like with the
saints just like
the hype and the you know just what it
i mean that's a separate avenue but it's
what that does to us thinking about
ourselves and
well it's not us thinking look what i
meant by ego is like
just being a little too prideful where
you're like right i know i'm right
and until you say sorry then we can just
not talk yeah right is that what we're
saying oh yeah totally yeah that's a
good point yeah it's like until you
figure out your side of it
yeah but then sometimes it's like you're
holding a a
grudge that's never that
that's never gonna be it's never gonna
be completed from the other side
yep so then it just leaves you sitting
there with the pieces and it's like okay
well what are you gonna do
you're gonna keep cutting your wrist
with these pieces are you gonna [ __ ]
you know you're gonna make them into
like a stained glass window and [ __ ]
move on
you know it's like um but it's hard and
sometimes you'll make the window and
that [ __ ] will fall apart again and
you'll [ __ ] get them back out
so true it's crazy it's on the ground
again
it's so beautiful for a minute yeah
for a weekend it made sense it's back on
the [ __ ] ground
it's gonna take me months to fix but
then also it's
like you don't really like i think you
don't realize like that you're the
story for people a lot of times like man
joe coy made had to make his own
had to convince these people like had to
and to me it would be the most obvious
thing like you know it always seems like
they're making they're looking for
diversity they're looking for
you know who else what other what are
they gonna get manny pacquiao to [ __ ]
tell jokes like
he can't even hold the microphone on the
gloves
i see them kept sleeping this microphone
it needs to be stickier
so it's like what was their plan how do
they and then
and then the gift you also give them by
reaching this audience
yeah man like [ __ ] bro that's a huge
gift
and so it's hard sometimes to feel when
you've been burned to then turn
around and realize that now you're just
gifting
you know um even more of
you know of an audience to this already
huge you know conglomerate
but that's just i'm just happy that that
you and i
live in that time where we got to show
these kids that hey you got to open
these doors yeah
no matter how we did it people also did
it by coming to see us by
not giving like fans that's what it is
support you know yeah man
people are like i'm gonna go see joe coy
and make this special because i know
that he
brings joy you know to me or i'm gonna
go be there at the wilton and have a
great time
and all those people don't realize that
all of that
goes into that moment where like
the executive finally says oh okay this
is a new piece of business for us
yeah exactly because that's how they see
it you're so right man
it's just it's tough when art and
and your heart me you know when when
when art and business meet each other
yeah
it's just it's a it's just a tough thing
man it is
here's a fellow right here who has a
wants to chime in yeah he looks like
he's been growing a baby hair mustache
for a long time
oh yeah this guy definitely theo what's
up joe hey what's up my name is troy i
live in ohio
i just got home from work long day at
the office
um a question to you two is how do you
stay positive knowing that your dreams
are
pretty much in the gutter you had to
cash in that corporate check in order to
uh
pay for some bills and um didn't end up
getting that dream you know both y'all
are standing comedians both of you all
do your thing but
for those others out there people like
me
what we got to say so we can keep on
trucking damn that how crazy that you
press play to that video after we just
said this
and that's just like nick's on point man
nixon pro next does a great job but um
man like there's a lot of people like
out there that think like that
and you know and and like yo it's it's
done for me
did you think like that at a point so
take us there and then take us out of
there
bro when i was working at um at
nordstrom rack i swear and tony rock
just got a deal with uh some i forgot
what the show was but it was being
produced by will smith
and you know and we're doing the laugh
factory every night
and i'm at nordstrom rack i'm crushing
every night bro
oh i'm wearing waiters outfits i got
mustard and [ __ ] on my chest and i'm
crushing
you know alongside tony and dane and bob
saget like
i'm [ __ ] slaying bro but then i'm
shelving shoes and i'm trying to buy
diapers and i'm just trying to make
these dvds to sell
and barely shelving shoes i'll be honest
at nordstrom rack yeah man rarely do you
get a match
rarely and by the way when i say
shelving shoes i'm just grabbing the
[ __ ] that's on the floor
and throwing it back on the rack oh i've
left in a sandal in a boot oh
100 easily oh man when they
always came to ask me for a size and i
go back there i literally went back
there
to not look for that [ __ ] size i gave
two shits
it was a five minute break for me and
then i came back and i'm like
i can't find it i think someone that
tried it on left it out
there good luck and you just see this
[ __ ] like what
my god can someone pick up these [ __ ]
shoes there's so many
it was like supermarket sweet for your
feet i feel like that's real
that was insane i remember i was walking
down the aisle because i had to pick up
shoes
and put them in a trash can and then you
fill up the trash can then you re
restock it right as i'm going down each
aisle
there's a lady that had a shoe on and it
didn't work and she just kicked it
and and we both our eyes locked i'm like
you [ __ ] and then she's like
i'll get it i'm like yeah [ __ ] go get
it and won't you get the rest
you're the reason for this mess you
[ __ ]
she's just in there this ursula footwear
yeah yeah she's just trying them on and
kicking them off
but um but what i was saying is uh dude
there was times where i wanted to quit
man
i just wanted to quit i was i was
getting so mad
you know you see all these guys just
getting stuff man
and you're just like dude what am i
doing why am i doing this even my mom's
telling me just get a full-time job
already
like your son's getting older now and
not older but he was like
two but she's like you gotta start
thinking about you know
school what kind of school what kind of
insurance are you going to get your son
like you don't have a
a job like you're working part-time like
like and
that [ __ ] is in your ear but it's also
like reality you're like
yeah i got to start thinking about my
son maybe i'll go
be a manager at a bank or something like
i'll throw in the towel i don't know
so yeah a lot of that was happening but
i was like no i refuse
i couldn't do it man i just kept selling
to i you know i shot it
there's an hour special floating out
there i know someone has it
but i remember paying someone 500 bucks
or something like that
for like three cameras to go shoot me
somewhere wow and i was gonna sell that
as my special because everyone else was
getting specials
and i couldn't get one i was like i need
a special and i went shot it was like
somewhere on sunset boulevard some
art museum or something like that and i
went shot it
and it's out there yeah it's it's
floating out there somewhere man that's
awesome yeah
that would crush if you got your hands
on that i know crazy right
yeah i'd still find that and sell that
nikoi crazy right um
you know i used to burn dvds at my
friend chris oh yeah yeah did you buy
the three disc tower and you burned them
like that
yes yeah i did that too dude i caught
that thing i put it in my butt
take it to wherever to [ __ ] really
loony bin or whatever set that [ __ ] up
in the hotel
what and [ __ ] and burn those things all
right
the name of the of the dvd on it
dude some of the sketches on it they
weren't even [ __ ] mine they were the
[ __ ] i found the internet
dude oh that's funny that's so funny
totally broke there was some [ __ ] that
someone was just like this black guy
singing dude it was like i don't even
know what this [ __ ] is
theo's favorite things to watch that was
the name of your dvd
at one time hey guys i'm theo vaughn
these are some of the funniest things i
like to watch
thank you for buying it
dude one time a lady bro uh she i just
sold her the case on accident she got
home he came the next day
oh there was no no dvd in it broke my
heart man and i would print off
down in the in the lobby of the business
area i would print off like all the
little dvd inserts
and put those things in man oh funny you
want to know what i did
i uh my friend chris worked at
blockbuster video
and you know this is they would buy dvds
right but it would be
sony and all that right the the covers
but they wanted their
covers to say blockbuster on the inside
of it so they would take those covers
and throw them away and replace those
covers with
uh blockbuster covers wow and they would
have garbage bags full
bro i had thousands of blockbuster cut
like whatever those covers you know what
i'm doing yeah there's cases i had
cases that's what they were called i had
so many of those man that's classy and
that's
and that's what i i put my sleeve in
that it looked like a legit dvd bro
that's awesome i even scanned a barcode
and it's in the bottom right corner
no i'll i'll send you a picture of it i
bet i think it's like it's probably soup
yeah if you scan it or probably say
campbell's i'm not even joking
i even got the logo that said dvd and i
put it on the on the spine of the thing
yeah i went got those printed off at a
legit printing company
it said joe coy's dvd volume one
because jay-z had a volume one
i sold those for five bucks a pop
but you buy a stack for a hundred bucks
right yeah it was a stack for 100 bucks
you get 100 dvds
and i sold them for five bucks a pop man
after profit i mean your profit was 400.
oh you could make yeah dude if you were
making some money man
because you you didn't make any money
going to do the work
no you never made money on those
weekends you know i remember i went 20
over about 10 years i i had 27 000 i
think in credit card debt just from
doing the road you know and it was just
man that was scary that was that was
pretty scary
but i think with having a dream or how
you bounce back into it man
i think one thing that's interesting
about these days is
you can all you can start so many new
things like you couldn't back in the day
yeah you know like rarely back in the
day did someone go from being like a
realist like a minor in a coal mine
like a real estate yeah you know but you
could do fracking now and then two
months later you could be mixing beats
like
[Laughter]
you could be dj weddings and i think
there's unique ways you can find
to create talent and create like some
type of revenue for yourself if you want
you know what i said the other day um
with all the tools that these kids have
now right they have
so many tools man you can make your own
book you can make your own magazine you
can make your own movie in the palm of
your hand and it's getting easier
legit your own movie your camera is
legit
this close to being a red camera yeah
like it's the quality is so good
and everything is in the palm of your
hands
and what i'm trying to say is if you're
not doing something
because you have an excuse because you
need something else
you're literally just lazy right and
that's that's your
only problem it has nothing to do with
what you got or how much money you got
or
or uh i need this or i need that you are
literally
lazy you're a lazy person and that's the
only thing you need to work on
and you can and that and that's
something that can be kind of cured you
know and not even to look at it like
also maximizing your laziness yeah man
you know like if you're going to be lazy
be lazy but also have some semblance of
a plan of when you're not going to be
yeah but yeah i think i i feel like
you know your dreams can change at any
time i mean nick was a
degenerate gambler yeah and a drunk nick
yeah thank you
nick dropped out of school yeah both of
those things still so
yeah okay yeah i want you i want
everyone to know i i know nick
as well corolla and
and he would roll up and go hey man uh
the trunk of my car is missing
where is it uh it's behind a bar
yeah and then when i did get fired yeah
theo likes to say pick me up off the
free agent
yeah he was on cbs sports fantasy yeah
yeah
he was always great man nick was always
great yeah
yeah next one of a kind man he's a
unique guy he's a degenerate gambler
but nick was living in his car and nick
went to vegas to play cards
he's it's close i played i played
full-time online poker
after college and i dropped out but then
separately
i just quit my job full-time job in
minneapolis and drove out here and lived
in my car until i got the internship at
corolla and he
hired me full-time but like literally
two work in podcasting
so i think there's ways yeah there's
just like i think there's different
times in your life too when it is tough
or like this gentleman's saying you know
yeah you know he might be at a different
point in his life you might have a wife
or kid some responsibilities you might
have a family member you're responsible
for taking care of
yeah there's a guy justin mcclure will
you look him up real quick on facebook
so he's a comedian and uh he ended up
getting married
and he has two daughters and now they
have a
uh like a facebook live show
that's like a really popular show really
and it
and he just you know we worked together
a couple of times really really nice guy
hard worker um and he just kind of
figured out how to make
something work for him and now they have
like a family show that
yeah you know that helps bring in
revenue for their family and stuff like
that and
it's really it's on facebook that's cool
man when you travel down that path and
you stay
on that path it eventually works out it
works out for something i think like
sometimes you don't know where
where the path is going to go and that's
the hardest part like knowing like
because i i used to do this thing called
crank texting where i would just text
strangers right
like just text random phone numbers yeah
and i would just say hey what's up right
yeah
and then i get into a conversation
sometimes and somebody would think i was
an old friend or something hey is this
randall and it's like yeah i haven't
heard from you in a while and then
next thing you know i'm asking if i can
come stay the night and it's like you
know i'm in this
crazy conversation that makes no sense
right that's not even real yeah
like i was in relationships with people
like oh bro crazy stuff
crazy stuff so i mean i texted probably
about 40 000 numbers over a couple of
period are you serious dude i was so
lonely i would text
i would text back this is when you were
on the road or you were just you were
just doing this this was all the time
did you bring up crank text nick
this was all the time um i would just
start texting strangers yeah i just got
into it and sometimes i would
uh just text just a group of people you
know just cranktext.com
um do you renew this
domain every year i think so
let's just see if it's still up
so obviously it needs to be adjusted
here for the screen somehow
but yeah you get into different
conversations like i would text people
in a certain area code like in indiana
and i'd be like we're raising money for
uh civil war reenactments after school
team right
and you get into real conversations
people start leaving your voicemails and
next thing you know you have this whole
conversation then you can take it
and you post it in here right so you get
into like you know this one was one i
would text thank you for what's that the
hellman's one
thank you for entering the love your
helmets contest we'll be contacting you
once the judges have reviewed all
entries
good luck and thank you for loving your
helmets you just send that to strangers
and people like what in the [ __ ] you
talking about dude
or you sent him a picture you know oh
hellman's man
and then they have to reply just so you
anyway but anyway i got an insane
conversation i would text a group of
people
and i would be like oh ricky won third
place and i would get a picture of an
asian kid with a trophy and just send it
to all of them in a mass text right
and so somebody would be like who's
ricky right and somebody would like take
me off this chain right
and somebody would be like oh bless his
heart man and then
somebody else would be like who in the
[ __ ] is this man
and i'd be like if some of you guys
cared if you had been there you'd if
you cared more you'd have been there to
see him win right yeah so anyway i get
in this crazy conversation with people
and i would just save and put them
online anyway fast forward that was your
idea
right that was my idea right this was
probably a decade ago so howie mandel
was looking for somebody to host
a prank show yeah so i had done this
for years man i'd spend a ton of money
paying people to edit them up
um spend a ton of time ton of time
and he's like oh i like your prank
website
and so that's how i got a job hosting
his prank show
so he saw it he saw it yeah and so it
was like
i'd spent all this time doing it and it
wasn't
getting anywhere yeah i just didn't have
the pr to make it pop
and uh and then it got me a job on his
show and it was it wasn't
it was you know it wasn't like my type
of show really but it was a great
opportunity it gave me enough money
where i was able to then to pay back the
comedy debt that i built up
yeah and you also have a relationship
with howie and now i still have a
relationship with him yeah which is
great so
which then introduced me he got me on to
like arsenio hall one time to perform
just little things so it's just like you
just don't know what what you're doing
now where it could end you up
mm-hmm sometimes yeah and that yo and
when you give up on that
it's it's gone or when you stray off
that path yeah you know i mean
and go off into a different direction if
your heart isn't that way
it's nothing's gonna happen right yeah
your heart has to be there though your
heart has to be here and whether
no matter how bad the struggle is as
long as your heart
is there things will happen i i keep
saying that like
every time i go on this road something
just
just comes into into my path
it just it just happens you know what i
mean and then next you know what this
relationship starts and next you know
i'm building this and now i'm writing
this
and and that's what it is it's just
staying here man
once you give up and stray off like if i
would have became a manager like my mom
wanted me to be
i i'd be at wells fargo going hey man uh
let me tell you this one joke that i got
you're gonna love this one oh god here
comes that manager guys here he comes
again
here comes zinger he's always got a
pocket full of zingers
when i was living in my car i started a
website because they just released this
thing on nfl.com it was called the all
22 cam so you could actually see the
place because you can't see that on tv
you can see what safeties are doing and
i wanted to break down the x's and o's
and i bought a website called
packersfilmroom.com
and i didn't know i was doing but i
learned how to build a website and i was
living in my car so like 150 dollars for
a domain
at that time was a significant amount of
money and it
went for nothing it didn't do anything
but i learned how to build a website and
a bunch of that stuff when i got hired
at corolla
i immediately started doing some of that
stuff for them and i just learned it
yeah yeah so at that time it was a scary
investment but you were so
your heart was in it that that thank god
you did that
because it gave you the the tools that
you needed when you did
get the opportunity right doing doing
something is always better than doing
nothing
i guess what we're trying to say is risk
yes some risk there's
risk takers like there's risk takers
yeah but also you don't know what the
things you've been doing where that
those elements are going to be needed
yeah or when that value is going to pay
off
yes you just don't know when that value
is going to pay off sometimes man
um you know now nick has a a another mma
podcast and they do
they talk about gambling on fights right
so he probably didn't know
yeah yeah yeah i haven't really put one
out but i'll put some content online and
people like are into it it's fun
and it's just what i like to do so but
who knows you know who knows a decade
ago when he's you know
just you know playing online poker you
just don't know sometimes
and you still don't know that's the
amazing thing about life is that it'd be
like oh
i still didn't realize this little thing
that happened so long ago yeah is gonna
pay this unique dividend um
in a financial way or a spiritual way or
all types of ways that's crazy man my my
life from seattle
the the special that i had to shoot the
opening
joke was a joke i wrote uh
when i opened for corey holcomb on some
uh
nightclub that was out in a what is that
freeway the 18 or whatever just some
weird freeway when you're going towards
magic mountain and then
it goes palmdale it was out in palmdale
damn and i was opening for corey holcomb
and uh it was at a nightclub no one was
allowed to sit on the dance floor they
said on the outside of the dance floor
we performed in the middle of the dance
floor
because the owner didn't want you to
scratch up the dance floor
so uh with chairs and tables
yeah yeah yeah scratch dancing with your
[ __ ] so
i went up i killed i by the way every
comic always says they kill right
so i killed and then we're driving back
and i'm not getting any love from corey
you know what i mean like
i'm like so now i gotta like bait him
into a compliment and i'm like yo man i
destroyed that [ __ ] right he's like
yeah but um still don't know who the
[ __ ] you are [ __ ]
and i'm like what do you mean like like
i don't know who the [ __ ] you are like
who are you jokoy
you just did a bunch of [ __ ] well
you did all
that basically i was just doing the easy
[ __ ]
right to be funny right but i don't know
who you are
like who are you what are you and then i
swear to god man that whole ride was
just kind of like i mean we were still
joking around but in my head i was like
[ __ ] i gotta i gotta write about who i
am
wow and and i and uh and i by the way i
was still opening for corey by the way
and um i tell this story in my book
because it was such a
it was one of those moments where you
get you get hip checked
and you get hip checked hard because i
was i was killing so much and i thought
oh that's
i'm a comic i'm a comedian until you
until you open for a veteran
and he's like who the [ __ ] are you bro
like what what's your voice
do you know your voice what are you and
um
oh there it is next play and um and i
went home and i literally was just i
couldn't even sleep theo i just kept
looking at the ceiling just like trying
to figure out
how do i tell people who i am and i
never talk about my dad how can i save
my dad real quick without
going into it too deep and that's that
opening line that i say
in that uh special for live from seattle
was written that night from corey
holcomb
like 14 years ago wow it was a 14 year
old joke that i never used
is that crazy it's crazy man there's
jokes that i'll be afraid to use for a
long time
you know yeah and they'll finally come
to the surface but yeah it's amazing man
mixed plate that's the book guys if you
want to grab it
yeah man pre-order uh it's not out yet
no
march wow we're supposed to be out this
year but i can't do a book tour
oh yeah so we want to wait till it opens
up and
we might postpone we don't know but uh i
i still want to i want to be on the road
when that book comes out
yeah it'll be fun yeah man just interact
with people about it
we both did that sam adams deal man that
was because of you
yeah it was cool i wasn't even supposed
to be on that thing that was until theo
called
i'm glad i did it was that yours was
really cute man theo theo's amazing i
wanted everyone to know that
i thought yours was cool man let's watch
it real quick man
telling jokes for a living this is my
dream come true
i always wanted to be a comic and i love
it
i'm joe coy stand up comedian
and i'm here to toast my mother that
two-pack baby
harrison without her none of this would
have happened
i think a lot of people forget to just
be grateful
people do stuff for us and then we just
act as if that's what they were supposed
to do
yeah it also sucks when you help
somebody and they walk by and you're
like
some of the [ __ ] didn't even thank me
ungrateful [ __ ]
my mom sacrificed everything to give me
the opportunity to live my dream
and this coast was the best opportunity
for me to say thank you
you know when my mom and dad divorced i
was right around 10 11
and she became everything she was pretty
much the backbone of the entire family
when i said i want to be a comic her
head was like what
are you crazy is it your house i
remember
working in a shower store still doing
stand up at night my mom was just like
i told you stop doing this you're going
to be broke
no we live in a country where dreams are
possible and it can happen
just give me some time
since day one i wanted to make sure that
the world
could laugh and when i tell your story
on stage it's something that i'm very
proud of
for years i was like how am i going to
talk about my mom i didn't want to go up
on stage and just be like oh i'm
filipino and filipinos do this
if you listen you're going to be like oh
my mom does the same [ __ ]
i mean you're doing great and i'm proud
of you you wanted me to be a lawyer well
we digress now i see being a comedian my
goodness
i mean you're one thousand percent
secure
sam adams it's grassroots it's family
what i take from that is the same thing
that i got for my mom
and that's why sam adams is the best
beer for this toast
the reason why i brought you here today
is i wanted to toast you
this is hard harder than i thought
pretty lady man
it's a little too much you came to this
country was to give the kids an
opportunity that
you knew that you would never have
everywhere i go people will be yelling
your name
and they clap their hand and i know it's
because of you
so i also want you to know that i'm so
proud of you you see you started this
you're the reason why i've been able to
do this thank you for everything you
sacrificed
so this is for you and i love you
did your mom drink beer and toast you ah
you got me all right
so much thank you oh i always cry in
here
that's good yeah good i love it it's
cool
too you want some more yeah
you want some more
well i i didn't plan on watching it all
the way through but it's nice
it's a nice sentiment man you know it's
important oh man
it's you know it's hard to have like
moments like that with our parents i
think
it's hard to get to those moments and
then actually follow through and
actually have them
yeah like sometimes i'll have an idea in
my head like okay i want to talk to my
mom about this or say this
or you know tell a family member this
but when it comes down to the moment
i just don't really follow through the
way i want to
i'll back off at a moment when i have a
feeling of some sort that's
uncomfortable
yeah you're right it's weird man it is
weird
but it's important you know it's
important bro that was cool
i didn't know he was crying i was trying
to fight my there was
did you see me nick do this i looked out
like ah
man not now she's pretty lady man
dude uh dude did you hear what she said
that's that's when you know i'm not
lying about my mom when she goes
uh when i knew you were a thousand
percent secure oh
that those were those conversations when
she would tell me to quit
yeah secure that's a unique word people
don't just throw that around a lot of
times yeah she she was
all about benefits and health insurance
security retirement like dude like
that's military stuff yeah man really
that's my mom that's how she talk you
know she was married to
two soldiers so that's all she talks
about my mom has been talking about
retirement since
she was 36.
so you just live first talk about
retirement later
that's funny man yeah it's powerful man
it's interesting man it's interesting to
see
now thanks for uh calling uh those guys
by the way that was really cool of you
yeah that was great well they had a cool
campaign man mm-hmm
it was a cool campaign you did yours
with i did mine just with the audience
oh yeah so mine was just at the laugh
factory with the audience
brendan did his i think with brian yeah
who else sigura
shafir ooh how was segura's i didn't see
that one
um he might have done his wife
oh yeah probably yeah i gotta watch it
but pretty cool man um thank you man
yeah thank you man thank you for coming
in today and just chatting it was good
some of the things you said i needed to
hear just like you know just kind of
stay the road and just be reminded of
like
you know that i still want to be funny
and i want to like yeah you know to just
find that dream that passion
yeah you know and realize that i still
have stories that i want to tell
and even more so like who who am i
yeah man you know like i love telling
stories and i love telling
but sometimes it would be brave to even
get even more into who i am
i wish you would but that's why when i
said that last time about your cartoons
i'm like dude
this has to be a series it's like you
have a story after a story after a story
and they just keep coming out of you
yeah i can't wait to see all of them by
the way my son's a huge fan of yours oh
that's cool man yeah he loves you man
yeah he's a handsome guy he's growing up
huh yeah so oh yeah he's great
he's he's going to be 18 here pretty
soon i told him
we'll put him on the shelf yeah yeah oh
yeah
hang it oh we want him here you bought
him here forever i'm gonna send you the
picture man
my favorite part is when we both looked
down at and then we both looked at each
other and he's like
i'll i'll pick him up dad let me pick
him up
no [ __ ] yeah uh is does he does he have
a
funny vibe what's his vibe oh he's very
funny he's got it
um i don't know what he wants to do i
know he he loves making beats
but i really see him acting and man if
he could do stand-up
man i would love to open for my son man
oh that'd be cool
i would love it man i would love to just
retire and be like hey son can i
can i just do five minutes in front of
you i would love that that'd be so cool
that'd be so cool
have you ever known anybody that got to
do that i think only damon junior is the
only one i know
that's true that uh i don't know if they
tour but that would be dope to have
damon and damon jr
on the same ticket one of my favorite
nights ever i was over at uh
hunter hunter henry uh hunter hill has a
show
over at you said los ciena get the black
box over there and
damon wayans was then going to be there
and i grew up on living color
oh so by the way last stand i think
that's his special i think that's what
it's called hbo special
you guys you have to watch it it's great
it's a beast man i've seen it
crushes go watch it all right go ahead
i'm sorry to meet you but i
i told a joke and he i heard him laugh
at one point
it's in the back of the room and it was
like every moment of my childhood of
like impersonating
him on the street with my friends and
everything it was just it did all come
full circle it was real cool
that's so cool man it was pretty dope
mixed plate you can get it early
uh pre-order now right yes if you order
joey.com
and uh thanks so much for coming to
spending time with us nikki have
anything else
no thanks for coming joe dude that was
amazing yeah it's funny thank you
[ __ ] bro love you bro i love you now i'm
just floating
on the breeze and i feel like these
[Music]
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
in my bones but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself go
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
pants
and these rails that i've been riding on
they want something that they're damn
they're
girl now
[Music]